bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans les 7 8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine
handball plaisir a remporté la finale
senior de la coupe des yvelines contre
montigny le bretonneux
le score du match est sans appel 39 à 26
pour les plaisirs oil le résumé dans ce
magazine twirling bâton la troisième
édition de la soirée des champions
organisée ce mercredi soir au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
coup de projecteur sur cet événement et
sur ce score acquise organisateurs il
est des athlètes qui seront présentes
cyclisme le championnat minime cadet
s'est déroulée ce dimanche dans le
hameau de boissy à magny les hameaux
plus d'une centaine de coureurs classés
parmi les meilleures des semis n'ont pas
eu départ de la compétition
et puis nous parlerons également de
football américain et de l'équipe des
templiers d'elancourt qui fêtait ce
week-end ses 30 ans ont joué ce week-end
la finale de la coupe des yvelines de
handball seniors au gymnase de la
vendirent à saint-germain-en-laye
l'équipe de plaisir à soulever le
trophée en battant en finale monty
bretonneux 39 à 26 camille lambert pour
les images
la logique a été respectée en finale de
la coupe des yvelines seniors au gymnase
des lavandières de saint germain les ce
dimanche 19 juin les joueurs de plaisir
qui évolue en prénationale ont battu
montigné obtenu une équipe de division
honneur régionale le score est sans
appel 39 à 26 début de match un peu
compliqué
défensivement on n'était pas présent
mais qu'on a un à plus défendre un peu
plus fort sur l'homme on à la pige les
montées de balle des contre attaques
ce que j'ai pu faire l'écart en début de
deuxième et a passé on a défendu un peu
plus fort
les ballons
le disez
le long du match on les voyait qu'il
mettait un peu d'intensité
reste qu il était plus fort ce plan
physique
au plan des gabarits sur plan aussi sur
plan foncier au niveau des courses
mes joueurs étaient fatigués que les
heures de plaisir de match on savait que
ça allait être difficile mais une très
bonne chose de la part de
des collectifs saignant de vente il dit
une victoire importante pour les
plaisirs oies les jaune et noir ont raté
la montée pour la deuxième année
consécutive en terminant à la deuxième
place de prénationale derrière paris
sport club
selon le staff et les joueurs cette
coupe des yvelines récompense leur
saison encourageant à la coudée divine
pour se réconforter
romero et on va retourner dans ma partie
prochain objectif pour plaisir l'année
prochaine conserver la coupe des
yvelines et enfin accrocher la montée en
nationale 3 après le handball on passe
un autre sport spectaculaire le twirling
bâton
une grande soirée de toi ling bâton est
organisée ce mercredi soir au vélodrome
nationale 2 ce mercredi soir vers dans
la semaine de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
si vous ne connaissez pas encore ce
sport nous allons essayer d'y voir plus
clair avec dominique pouliquen le
vice-président de la ligue ile de france
jean baptiste dupont lui aussi vice
président de la ligue et avec les
twirleurs alan bean et malice calus
bonsoir bonsoir avoir commencé tout de
suite par la présentation de ce sport
dominique pouliquen est ce que vous nous
présentez ce sport il est importé des
etats-unis si je crois idéal a besoin
d'apporter des états unis dans les
années 70 il est arrivé très exactement
74 en france le ton que l'idée germe la
fédération existants 78 et à partir de
là c'est un essor en fait on france on a
pris une partie des majorettes qui
voulait faire du sport c'est devenu un
vrai sport reconnu par le comité
olympique français s'est de même en
italie je crois aux etats unis aussi
et voilà l'expression au fur et à mesure
du temps pour arriver aujourd'hui au
qatar où quatorze mille licenciés à peu
près en france donc un vrai sens un vrai
sport reconnu par le ministère des
sports reconnu par le comité national
olympique et sportif français
voilà un sport qui a sa place dans le
paysage français aujourd'hui jean
baptiste dupont quelle est la différence
avec les majorettes compare ce moment ce
sport en majorette quelle est la
différence avec se séparer de
comparaison à faire on est dans un
gymnase
les athlètes qui pratiquent le twirling
bâton sont des athlètes et des
compétiteurs alors que
partie majorette on va dire c'est vous
c'est plus dans la rue défilé donc là on
est plus sur une discipline sportive
avec des vrais compétiteurs
vous confirmez voilà tout à fait on fait
pas des défilés
en pratique c'est dans un gymnase c'est
un vrai sport enfin là c'est tout à fait
et vous essayez de sortir juste ce
stéréotype des majorettes
dominique alors ça ça perdure parce que
dans l'imagerie populaire voilà les
majorettes c'était gentil c'était mignon
avec les fanfares dans la rue alors ces
jeunes là n'ont jamais connu jean
baptiste l'a peut-être connu moi j'ai
connu à travers mes parents il ya très
très longtemps
donc j'ai pas de frustration
particulière vis-à-vis des majorettes
c'est simplement pas la même chose c'est
comme si on compare je sais pas les
choux et les navets ça n'a strictement
rien à voir encore une fois alors pour
donner une image claire c'est que dans
les années 80 en fait la ffg la
fédération française de gymnastique a
approché deux fédérations pour les
avaler c'était la grs et le twirling
bâton la grs a dit oui mais son entrée à
la ffg
on a dit non pour des raisons qui nous
est très propre à l'epo à l'époque on
voit ce qu'est la grc grosso modo c'est
très apparentes et donc on a pas on va
se battre pendant longtemps mais je
crois que la bataille elle est passée
elle était pour les gens des années 80
90 nous on est plus dans la bataille les
majorettes existe elle est fort
justement c'est u 7
c'est un et c'est un loisir le twirling
bâton existe a été en démonstration aux
jeux olympiques de sydney en 2000
par grâce au japonais voilà on va
continuer de travailler sur la
communication pour continuer à faire
connaître ce sport olympique dans les
prochaines années j'ose espérer être
encore vivant à ce moment là mais
mais l'américaine non parce que les
critères les critères olympiques sont
très sont très strictes ou déjà pour
commencer c'est une présence sur les
cinq continents ses 35 fédérations au
minimum reconnu par les comités
nationaux olympiques et ensuite ça
demande une rigueur que que le twirling
a dans certains pays la france le japon
les états unis mais très clairement on a
besoin de développer dans les autres
pays pour être au niveau des sports
olympiques et en plus on a pour
l'instant effectivement pas la portée
médiatique que demandent les jeux
olympiques puisque les jeux olympiques
sont beaucoup mercantile
à l'heure actuelle on compare aussi
souvent le twirling bâton au patinage
artistique par exemple ya un côté
esthétique dans dans le curling bâton
vous avez ce sentiment là également
oui dans l'idée et je pense que c'est
une bonne direction quand on fait le
comparatif dans le principe sur les
compétitions où on a une table deux
jurys où les athlètes sont jugés sur
leur appréciation sur l'évolution sur la
technique l'artistique tout sur tous ces
points là donc c'est vrai que sur ces
points là on peut avoir vraiment un vrai
comparatif on est proche du patinage
artistique sur l'artistique moi pourquoi
je viens de le dire
maëlys le twirling bâton généralement
quand tu annonces ou athées à tes
parents et tes amis que tu fais du temps
les bâtons qu'est ce qu'ils en pensent
c'est pas très connue encore donc mes
amis ne connaissait pas et puis ils ont
ils sont venus à mes compétitions et son
bien aimé s'est accroché ils vous
encouragent
oui ça derrière même chose voilà tout à
fait maintenant je pense que j'ai un peu
près mes amis ma femme qui me suivent
dans toutes les compétitions et même
internationale ils font le déplacement
pour venir nous supporter c'est un sport
assez physique
puisqu'on parle beaucoup et esthétique
et c est ce que c'est un sport physique
à l'âme s'est affaissé dans une vraie
préparation physique
si la souplesse la patience parce qu'on
ne peut pas réussir tout du premier coup
ça demande beaucoup d'envié aussi maëlys
on voit justement compétition alan là ce
mouvement expliquez nous faut beaucoup
de feux de la souplesse sa volonté le
bâton qui tout le monde que ce pourrait
être facile mais pas du tout c'est rien
que le lancer si c'est compliqué on peut
rajouter à temps pour pouvoir juste que
c'est compliqué voilà en fait parce que
c'est difficile à apprendre déjà assez
compliqué gelé d'un petit peu parce que
tout tourne autour du pouce sur les
lancers est en fait en fonction de la
direction de la main de la position du
pouce le bâton on peut partir à droite
ou à gauche donc déjà il faut avoir un
an c'est juste pour pouvoir faire
attraper juste elle est très très bas
lis un sport physique on en croit depuis
tout à l'heure chauffe beaucoup
d'énergie en lice oui il faut beaucoup
d'entraînement pour arriver à haut
niveau d'al ain plus beaucoup d'heures
d'entraînement par semaine et votre avis
comment généralement dans un
entraînement parce que vous travaillez
jamais très loin autrement dit d'abord à
l'échauffement qui durent 30 45 minutes
puis après on passe à la préparation au
niveau du bâton qui demande beaucoup de
temps aussi apprend répète c'est notre
enchaînement qu'on m'a présenté en
compétition de mini policard est-ce
qu'il faut avoir fait de la gymnastique
pour se lancer dans les longues attentes
oui alors il faut pas forcément
préalablement en avoir fait ça fait
partie de nos enseignements
en fait on
on parle de trois disciplines
différentes dans le temps du maton le
maniement du bâton la gymnastique la
danse et on rajoute interprétation qui
voit là au plus haut niveau on en a
besoin
donc la gymnastique fait partie des
enseignements qu'on donne théoriquement
dans les clubs les prudes plus structuré
on a des preuves de bâton on a des profs
de gym
donc forcément il faut 10 nast et
quelque part c'est ces deux athlètes
entre autres sont des gymnastes maniant
le bâton et justement quand on parlait
de lancer et la difficulté c'est qu'il
faut se rendre compte qu'on ne voit pas
sur un écran c'est que pour les plus
gros lancer typiquement de d2 le bâton
part aux alentours de 15 à 16 m quinze à
seize mètres pour se donner le temps de
faire les acrobaties gimmick en dessous
quinze à seize mètres
c'est très haut on a même des gymnases
internationaux qui sont un peu plus haut
pour des lancers encore plus compliqué
c'est dangereux mais surtout ça demande
une dextérité et beaucoup d'entraînement
en france on s'entraîne beaucoup au
japon
typiquement le champion du monde actuel
qui éduquait comada me disait il n'ya
pas très longtemps il s'entraîne six
heures par jour sauf le mercredi et le
samedi puisqu'il s'entraîne huit heures
et il est de repos les voit s'imposer 6
heures par jour pour réussir ses
salariés ce qui n'est ce qui n'est en
rien choquants c'est tout simplement le
rythme des sports études les sports
études en france s'entraîne sa ans quand
on fait de la natation en sport-études
sait on est on est dans le bassin à 6
heures le matin et on a nos six heures
d'entraînement par jour
on n'a pas encore le volume 2 de
licencier nécessaire pour pouvoir monter
ce type de sport-études canton canton de
3 ils s'entraîneront cinq à six heures
par jour
on va à présent parler de la soirée des
champions c'est la troisième édition
quel sera le programme de cette phrase à
la troisième édition est la plus grosse
des éditions jusqu'à présent puisque en
fait le concept c'est c'est un petit peu
pris de ce qu'on fait on gère ou de ce
qu'on fait en patinage artistique avec
les galas les galas avec les athlètes de
plus haut niveau donc on a pris les
finalistes du championnat de france
franciliens et cette année on a été pour
le moins performant puisque on a 44
franciliens qui se sont hissés à la
finale du championnat de france à saint
brieuc début juin dont maëlys et alan
évidemment et donc le principe c'est de
faire une grande soirée de démonstration
qui va durer aux alentours de 2h30 3h et
cette fois ci on a pris un lieu
prestigieux parce qu'on voulait être à
la hauteur de nos attentes en termes
d'organisation et on a choisi le
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
qui élevé idéal pour organiser ce type
de méfait alors le lieu idéal je vous
dirais voir mercredi à 23h30 quand on
aura fini
a priori pour l'instant oui puisque
c'est un petit peu showtime donc on a
des spots vidéo pour présenter chaque
athlète on a on a besoin de lumière on a
besoin d espace
on a besoin de place puisque mu n'a rien
on sera aux alentours de 700 spectateurs
on a besoin de son et le vélodrome pour
l'instant réunit tout ça notamment à
tracer écran géant on sait la qualité de
son personnel est instituée c'est
vraiment pour l'instant
voilà pour l'instant ça fait partie des
plus beaux lieux qu'on ait vu on a
organisé les championnats du monde en
c'était le dôme de villebon c'est ce
type de structure qui maintenant donc
maintenant à a besoin de toi ligne bâton
pour les grandes soirées comme ça oui
jean baptiste dernière question quel est
l'objectif de cette soirée
objectif c'est attirer encore plus de
monde vers le toit en battant absolument
c'est ce que vient nous décrire un petit
peu dominique dans le cadre dont on a
besoin pour pouvoir faire découvrir
cette discipline au plus grand nombre
et c'est vrai que vont l'opportunité
s'est fait sentir puisque cette année
c'était un peu plus vers les yvelines
qu'on pouvait organiser cette soirée
donc c'était assez intéressant de
trouver une structure qui répondent à ce
besoin
donc l'objectif effectivement ces deux
soirées c'est qu'on touche le plus grand
nombre que les gens soient sensibles ou
soient attirés ou aient envie de
découvrir une discipline
on disait maylis tout à leurs parents
portent très très connu je pense qu'on
va en parler
un petit moment de cette soirée entre
nous certainement mais les gens
extérieurs où les gens de la communauté
urbaine de saint quentin je pense que
s'ils ont un petit peu de temps mercredi
soir à consacrer ils peuvent venir les
portes leur sont grand ouvertes malice
il y aura du spectacle on espère vous
allez produire le spectacle
oui ok c'est noté merci à vous d'être
passé on se bat on suivra avec attention
cette soirée en on reviendra sur cette
compétition dans le prochain cette fille
de sport merci à vous d'être passé sur
ce plateau
après cette page toualy mme batho zoom
sur le cyclisme en championnat minimes
cadets étaient programmés ce dimanche
dans le hameau de boue et si à magny les
hameaux plus d'une centaine de coureurs
classés parmi les meilleures des divines
ont pris le départ de la compétition
montage est signée romao respini
d'esprit des dépassements des
retournements de situation le
championnat départemental minimes et
cadets a tenu toutes ses promesses
dimanche 19 juin magny les hameaux pour
l'occasion entre a cédé 3,2 km a été
dessiné dans le hameau de boue et si par
le vélo-club de montigny-le-bretonneux
organisateurs de l'épreuve des coureurs
devaient parcourir la distance dix fois
a tracé sur lequel tout le monde a sa
chance
un homme en forme et y'a pas besoin
d'être spécifiquement un grimpeur s'est
pas c'est simplement un homme costaud
comme il y avait du plat juste après la
côte d'opale et fallait rester au même
rythme et jusqu'au jusqu'à 200 fois les
difficultés que j'ai rencontrées c'était
le vent et la côte le vent ce n'est pas
parce qu'il fallait bien se passer
les fois trouvé le vent s'est pas fait
ma fille difficile et après les coûts et
va falloir les vents au total une
centaine de cyclistes classé parmi les
meilleurs du département à participer à
l'événement les sportifs ont réalisé une
moyenne de 32 km heure chez les minimes
et de 34 km heure chez les cadets y
avait des coureurs qui étaient bons
surtout pour une arrivée en côte qui
aurait pu qui aurait pu me battre
les gens que le niveau est jamais jamais
assez élevé mais
mais bon disons que
bon en minimes cadets minimes qui sont
balles parmi les meilleurs
d'ile-de-france disons dans les dix
premiers à la sortie de cette course
maxime leroy de conflans est premier du
championnat des yvelines dans la
catégorie cadets et erwan louvier
premier chez les minimes
une nouvelle compétition pourraient être
organisées l'année prochaine par le vélo
club de montigny le bretonneux toujours
à magny les hameaux
l'étoile sportive de trappes a réalisé
une grosse saison sur plusieurs tableaux
l'équipe fanion l'équipe une a terminé à
la quatrième place du classement de
promotion d'honneur et les u17 vont
monter pour nous parler de ces très bons
résultats nous recevons sur ce bateau le
président du club mustapha larbaoui le
coach de l'équipe senior arnaud mbc le
capitaine de l'équipe senior hamidou
sissoko et l'entraîneur des u17 à nice
one bonsoir ce soir alors on va
commencer tout de suite c'est par
l'équipe une comment expliquer ces bons
résultats président mode d'abord c'est
pas qu'une saison en réalité
l'équipe une se construit depuis
quelques temps maintenant et ses
résultats sont quand même le travail de
à la fois de cette saison mais des
saisons précédentes et puis surtout du
travail colossal qui fait par les
éducateurs à nice et éducateurs arnaud
lait auquel cas il ya un gros travail
qui fait sur la jeunesse qui viennent
attribué fin parents qui viennent
contribuer et donc et en même temps à
midi ici présents qui est avec moi
depuis maintenant 14 ans au club
donc c'est ce c'est ce mixte entre des
anciens qui sont là et qui sont là
depuis le début
ils sont très peu nombreux pour ça j'en
profite pour les remercier encore avec
stéphane et puis un véritable colonne
vertébrale clair votre clairement ce
club a maintenant quelque chose de très
solides entre les 4 et consolider et
c'est l'effort de des joueurs des
anciens une bardée des jeunes qui ont
été formés au club parce qu'en 14 ans
ils sont passés des u 6 u 7 à u 20
seniors donc voilà c'est vraiment la
construction sur le long terme à l'om
billy vous finissez quatrième est ce
qu'il ya un petit regret malgré tous
n'ont pas eu à nous accostons faute à
tout ce qu'on a vu c'est de cette saison
dans le feu en fait un coup tu n'étais
pas pour l'année dernière mettant les
anciens que les gens comme le président
donc finalement fini quatrième avec
un bel espace blessé en venir à une
équipe car elle manage de 21 ans donc
très jeune donc là du coup ce n'est pas
de coutume en fait on va travailler
seulement on a eu la bonne surprise en
fait lors des matches de coupe de france
ils vont passer leurs racines une dh
avec six joueurs de mode innovant donc
regarder l'avenir et qu'est ce qui vous
a manqué hamidou sur cette saison
peut-être pour pour terminer aux deux
premières places
on dirait un peu de chance peut-être je
sais pas mais bon bah bah ouais ouais
c'est vrai que des bonnes équipes comme
louis qui monte au xxi termine à 20
points de vous ils ont mérité
il était clairement trop fort avec la
saison qu'ils ont fait résultat qu'on
voit très clairement il pouvait
rivaliser a vanté cette année avec avec
une équipe comme oy
non cette année en tout cas on pouvait
rivaliser mais c'est à nantes que
c'était ils avaient la chance du
champion donc on les avait tout pour
réussir
ça va des champions pour oui oui
clairement clairement ça choque qu'on
force par destin à chaque fois nous
c'est de la construction qui nous fait
donc ce n'est pas sur une saison qu'on
veut vraiment forcer les choses on il a
calmement on sait que de toute façon sur
ce plateau on reviendra pour vous dire
la dh la dhr la dsr la dh on vous le dis
je la vis probablement dit il ya une
plus d'une dizaine d'années un ça va
ça va se construire dans le temps on est
dans la construction donc il ya des
équipes qui sont très très pointu sur
leur équipe une
c'est le cas de sa commande bien c'est
le cas de saint leu également et où il
met les dernières s'étaient chatou
l'année d'avant c'était nanterre il ya
toujours des grosses équipes mais
regardant le club dans sa globalité des
u6 u7 u8 u9 u10 peut continuer comme ça
les u17 qui font un qui performent cette
année c'est la globalité qui que du club
qui fonctionne bien et qui grandit et il
y contribue
parce qu'ils contribuent également
l'éducatif d'un club c'est au delà de au
delà de la une il ya l'académie il faut
qu'ils aient la section féminine
maintenant c'est tout ça et tout le
monde y contribuer on va passer
justement aux u17 vous allez monter les
deux équipes montrent cette année je ne
me trompe pas c'est ça ces deux équipes
montent
est ce que c'était un résultat inespéré
ou est ce que vous attendiez à ce
résultat
non non c'est nous s'est fixé cet
objectif
en cours de saison en fait parce que
justement on a vu le sérieux des gamins
la bonne dynamique et qu'ils ont eue et
puis la bonne état d'esprit aussi
donc du coup du coup on s'est fixé cet
objectif on pouvait pas ce qu'on avait
l'effectif assez large pour pouvoir être
dans les deux tableaux au dessus donc du
coup du coup voilà ça a bien fini
premières comme comme équipe et il ya
une grosse génération qui arrive à
trappes
chez les u 17 chez les u17 enfin je vous
dirai pas une grosse génération mais oui
il ya de quoi faire un vrai boulot vous
voulez pas qu'il prenne la grosse tête
c'est pour ça on a exactement les gros
génération qui arrive vraiment pas
franchement chaque année c'est le
travail qui s'améliore de plus en plus
nos enfants sont là nos jeunes sont là
mais c'est la construction du club qui
fête qui fait la différence
on est vraiment dans la construction et
les enfants en profitent bien sûr bon au
passage au salaire facile comme ça mon a
transpiré jusqu'à la dernière minute de
la saison axa monte il pour la lune 17
unis la doit à la dernière minute on
était encore en match quasiment nul dans
toute une saison pour se voir monter sur
la dernière minute du jeu vrai également
pour la 17 b donc ils nous ont fait
transpirer et
comme l'équipe de france ensemble par la
pareille hamidou les u17 il faut les
intégrer petit à petit dans l'équipe
oui bien sûr on peut essayer du
potentiel et que jour ils sont nés à
jouer en équipe première fausse intégrer
petit à petit pourquoi pas aussi s'ils
peuvent prendre la place qu'ils
apprennent falloir bosser à bon compte
et les intégrer l'année prochaine on va
prendre en compte le temps comme un
homme qu'il a 19 ans que ça vaut quand
même
maintenant on fera apparaître choses par
étapes effectivement après idc que j'ai
chaque inflige à son humour et puis que
les meilleurs 17 puisse évoluer en fait
un lieu ces personnes de se retrouver
aussi et puis garder tout ce qu'on
voyait plus elle vaut plus moyen pour
juger d'un postulat a fait un peu club
d'allocations arnaud vous avez pris
l'équipe en cours de route cette saison
après avoir remplacé motion a aussi est
ce que vous voulez construire un nouveau
groupe la saison prochaine ou repartir
avec les mêmes et ne rien rien changé
est ce qu'on voulait travailler en
groupe
en fait ils essaient de coups sûrs et se
sont consultés donc on va prendre le
temps ses futurs moteurs avec les
cartons qu'en fait la prison loin milou
qui est capitaine emblématique et les
quelques 2009 qui nous ont rejoints en
cours de saison aussi
et puis à s'intégrer tous ceux qui sont
prêts à intégrer le projet qui consiste
à être sérieux appliqués et puis après
appel à des fins de couleurs du club
quoi merci à vous d'être passé sur ce
plateau on vous souhaite de bonnes
vacances et une bonne intersaison et de
travailler dur pour être au top
la saison prochaine et de monter c'est
notre ami devant la saison prochaine
c'est la montée merci à vous on passe
maintenant reste de l'actualité sportive
on commence à trouver que par du
football et l'euro 2016 la france qui
s'entraînent à clairefontaine dans les
yvelines a conclu les phases de poules
par un match nul et vierge contre la
suisse 0 à 0 un résultat qui lui permet
de terminer en tête du groupe dans le
village foot de monty bretenoux la
vibrer au rythme des bus et des frappes
sur les poteaux de paul pogba et dimitri
payet
on écoute les réactions des supporters à
la fin de la rampe match pas mal du tout
surtout en première mi temps pas mal de
rythme un petit peu moins en deuxième on
a un peu plus subi mais l'essentiel
c'est de finir premier de la poule et du
coup c'est réussi avec le match nul il
suffisait d'un match nul donc l'aventuré
continue et on sera derrière derrière
les bleus pour le prochain match était
compliqué hein
et si en fait ce qui ils galèrent contre
la suisse mais après je me demande
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire quand
l'allemagne puisque la suisse est pas
une équipe non plus trop forte et ils
galèrent contre eux donc ça veut dire
quand l'allemagne vont de paire d'offre
car 5 0 comme ça s'échauffe déçu déçu
parce que très lent petit baballe ont ce
pas trop il ya eu deux tirs sur la barre
qui nous réjouissent un peu c'est tout
la france jouera dimanche prochain
contre le 3e du groupe c d ou e les
adversaires potentiels pour les bleus
l'irlande du nord la république tchèque
ou encore la suède
toujours au chapitre euros les irlandais
qui ont pour camp de base versailles
sont dans le groupe e
baptisé groupe de la mort avec la
belgique d'éden hazard l'italie de
bouffonne et la suède de zlatan
ibrahimovic avant leur dernier match
contre les italiens les irlandais sont
derniers du groupe avec un petit point
et une différence de buts de moins 3
l'aventuré devrait s'arrêter dès le
premier tour de 7 euros pour les
britanniques
de son côté la russie qui s'entraînent à
croissy sur seine et dans le groupe b
avec l'angleterre le pays de galles et
la slovaquie au classement les russes
sont derniers avec seulement un petit
point pris depuis le début de la
compétition et devront battre ce lundi
20 juin le pays de galles de gareth bale
pour espérer se qualifier pour les
huitièmes de finale en terminant ce
magazine par un anniversaire les
templiers d'elancourt en fêté ce samedi
leurs 30 ans avec une fête au complexe
sportif europe des petits matchs des
démonstrations une cheerleader c'est une
exposition photos autant sort en
retraçant l'histoire du club étaient
programmées pendant toute la journée on
écoute les réactions sur cet
anniversaire au micro de mélanie pauli
qu'est ce que çà mau sur wii
effectivement que j'ai pris 30 ans
puisque
j'étais leur premier entraînement des
cormorans qui sont devenus par la suite
layton les templiers
donc voilà ça nous rajeunit pas mais
j'ai une très belle fête aujourd'hui
voilà on retrouve les anciens tout le
monde a pris trente ans il y a pas que
moi un plaisir de faire partie de cette
famille et une envie de relève
envie de prendre le relais et de
produits succéder à nos coachs plein de
souvenirs plein plein d'amitié plein de
voyage et voir des gens que j'ai pas
revu depuis
20 25 voire 30 ans tout début et qui
vont arriver les uns après les autres au
fil de la journée
c'est la fin de cette fille de sport
merci d'avoir suivi vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission ripé sur notre
site internet et sur youtube très belle
soirée sur tv fil 78